y la influencia de correa no solamente a
la luz de estar fuera del país sino de
ser
un personaje que está condenado tiene
una condena en firme no es decir es una
persona que está huida en este momento
de la justicia en su papel ha sido
fundamental en la candidatura de aráoz
es decir durante todo durante toda la
campaña de rauch si no era correa
directamente acompañándole a distintos
mítines a través de redes sociales y
demás lo teníamos presente junto con las
imágenes del candidato en toda la
publicidad de es decir de alguna manera
la candidatura de graus representa la
selección de guerra fa el correa en
representa
la posibilidad no que ambiciona no
avizoran un porcentaje importante del
electorado de poder volver a aquellos
años de gobierno de rafael correa en ese
sentido todos los que alguna vez y en
ese grupo me incluyo yo dijimos que la
influencia del liderazgo de correa iba a
mejorar a medida que pasa el tiempo y
con la distancia pues se ha visto
completamente refutada no es yo creo en
una de las grandes
una de las grandes variables que
explican
la cantidad de votos que hará vos ha
logrado a abarcar el de acuerdo con los
exit polls porque de acuerdo con los
resultados oficiales solamente tenemos
del 2% las dantas actas computadas pero
los exit polls ya le dan a área bus más
o menos entre un 34 y un 35 por ciento
de la votación
entonces la influencia de correr está
ahí es importante y es importante
también la digamos como puede todavía
movilizar a un porcentaje muy importante
del electorado luego también desde los
debates entre comillas porque no fueron
debates como tal se vio una
repolarización si se quiere del país de
nuevo entre esa división entre
correístas y anti correístas no era una
línea divisoria que de alguna manera
había quedado oculta detrás de la
pandemia ya había quedado oculta detrás
de los problemas económicos que enfrenta
el país pero que volvió a sumar con
fuerza y de hecho
lo que al final yo creo logra movilizar
a gran parte del electorado a favor de
arauca